ah hello Peter in Oliver I should say I
used to teach with Peter at American
University so that's why I'm using first
names when we start by one or both of
you talk about what the major theme of
this very interesting history is and how
you came to write it I was invited by
Peter 1996 to go to his class in
American University or his teaching
Oliver Stone's America at one of his
classes and that he was very popular
I went very impressed with it was the
range of the students and afterward at
dinner Peter suggested that yeah there
was a great story in the atomic bomb and
the atomic bomb always fascinated me
because I was born that year after it
was dropped and it controlled I was in
New York City and we were the center of
the world and my father was Republican
and a conservative and he'd served in
World War two with eisenhower so the
bomb was was the umbrella the mushroom
under which I grew and everything we did
was in the in the in the shadow of that
so I was curious about it then he said
well the bomb story really does have
another origin he went into 1930s
because the scientists he'd written a
book about the scientists of the
thirties but above all he mentioned this
figure about Henry Wallace and how he
could have been president in 1944 but he
was bumped by the political bosses and
that led of course to the 45 decision by
Truman so now we became the origin of a
grand idea for a documentary or a movie
and he tried he wrote a script it didn't
work for me
but 10 years later it haunted me that
story in Washington another day you
still teaching the class and I came back
and he we decided to go ahead and do a
documentary about Wallace and the bump
that one hour turned into a altima into
a bigger our eyes were bigger than our
stomachs and I think we tried for a 12
hour national security state story from
1940s to now actually we started in 1900
the philippine-american war but the
spanish-american war and
ended up in 2012 but we started in 1940
in the series now the book two years at
into our series we decided hey this is
getting very serious and we know I'm
going to be called on this because of my
background in making movies they're
going to say this is part fiction part
fantasy but we decided to go ahead and
go with this book and it turned Peter
took over the book I was running the
serie the film and we were cross feeding
all the time and checking each other
constantly but I took about four and a
half five years now and that's where we
are today what Anthony
yeah that's pretty thorough we've been
friends for that whole period since 1996
and then we decided we were going to go
ahead with this project and we had a
sabbatical I thought we could do it and
that year was going to be a 60-minute
documentary I go to see Oliver in New
York two weeks later and that was a
ten-hour series so what I thought was
going to take one semester ended up
taking four years four and a half years
so it's been a big project it was
important for us to add the book because
I was surprised how little information
you can convey in a 60-minute
documentary if in each episode and so
the book we wrote an 800-page book we
actually cut out one hundred fifty two
hundred pages to get it down to eight
hundred pages because there's so much
that we wanted to tell but we also
wanted to give the the footnotes and the
sources and the much more detailed
discussion of this material because we
know we're going to be challenged we're
offering a perspective that is not the
mainstream perspective and we wanted to
have our sources out there when we do
get challenged and essentially it was
addressed to people like my daughter and
my sons who had been in height a high
school level history we wanted it to
gear it so that you could read this book
and see this documentary it's tough but
you could understand it at sixteen
seventy a college level and you start to
specialize and much of this is available
to students and they go but we really
wanted to get my daughter's history
books even today when you get for
example to the Hiroshima there's no
mention of an alternative possibility
it's the Americans had to drop the bomb
to save American law
because the Japanese were fanatics you
don't hear about the Russians on an
equation and you don't hear about the
other choices that could be had
now as Peter said obviously this book
has already stirred up controversy and
you expected it to and I wonder if we
could move into some of the areas that
you like that obviously you know
historians like to argue about and and
that will will and have already elicited
commentary on different sides the Cold
War is obviously central to what you're
writing about here and to the film and
perhaps I'm wrong but as I read it your
argument pretty much is that is that the
United States is primarily to blame for
for the begin of the Cold War that that
Stalin and the Soviets would have been
would have been open to and were
welcoming a continuation of the of the
wartime alliance between the two
countries but it was American actions
primarily with some allies British for
example which really going on the Cold
War is that is that an accurate
portrayal I would say that's that's
accurate
we don't certainly don't consider the
Stalin blameless in all of this and we
certainly don't downplay Stalin's
brutality or the the terrible things
that were done in the name of the Soviet
Union under Stalin's leadership we think
that's important to factor in but in
terms of if we look at the broad sweep
of the history of the United States
relationship with the Soviet Union
beginning in 1917 1918 when the United
States first sends troops into Soviet
Union as part of a broader counter
revolutionary force led by the British
than the United States refusal to
recognize the Soviet Union until 1933
under Roosevelt and then then during the
30s the Soviet Union was pushing very
hard for international consensus and
trying to stop Hitler and they were
leading the anti fascist forces globally
and the Communist Party was very
instrumental in the anti-fascist
movement in the United States as a
result of that but then during the war
where after Germany attacks the Soviet
Union in 1941
then the United States and the British
decide they're going to support the
Soviet Union because it's key to the
British chances of surviving the war to
bring the Soviets keep the Soviets in
the war there's always risk caught so
off guard that the British were
concerned the Americans are concerned
that the Soviets were going to
capitulate at that point so the United
States offers several things and the
Soviets make several demands and the
United States promises material and had
a hard time delivering that for a number
of reasons in the first couple of years
but this Allah says if you give us that
those airplanes and them that other
equipment that we need we can stay in
the war the United States tries
Roosevelt makes a sincere effort of
other people are not as quite quite as
sincere in providing that the Soviets
second demand was they want to some of
the same territorial concessions that
they had gotten from Hitler in the 1939
pact and but their main demand was for
the second front they were fighting this
is the history of this period the
Americans and the British throughout
most of the war were fighting ten Nazi
divisions combined the Soviets alone
were fighting 200 at least through June
of 44 and so so they were desperate for
the United States to open up a second
front in Western Europe and the British
and Roosevelt asked Stalin to send
Molotov and a top general to Washington
in May of 42 and and in June of 42 the
United States issues a public statement
saying we're going to open up the second
front before the end of the war before
the end of the year in 1942 we promised
that publicly and yet then we don't open
up the second front till June of 44 and
that's partly because the British
refused to go along with this in the
United States and the British get
involved in what Marshall calls
periphery pecking in northern Africa
Marshall and Eisenhower furious that the
United States didn't open up the second
front that the United States went
instead to basically defend the British
Empire because this will lead to the
Cold War well because there's going to
be a lot of mistrust between the United
States and the Soviets beginning during
the war so as we argue that the seeds of
the Cold War actually are visible during
the war
nay's finally open up the second front
of June of 44
and and there's certain tensions of
course because the fact that we delayed
the second front means that the Soviets
had on their own largely defeated the
Germans after Stalingrad and we're
pushing across Central Europe and
Eastern Europe moving toward Berlin
during that time so the United States
comes in we'd lost the military
initiative by that point and we lost the
diplomatic initiative at that point and
so there are certain deals being made
deals between Churchill and Stalin in
October of 44 dividing up dividing up
yes we also they'll get the British will
get 90 percent in Greece the Russians
who get 90 percent in Bulgaria and
Hungary and May they divided it up that
way it was pretty cynical and so but
when Roosevelt dies in April of 45 his
last telegram to Churchill was we always
have these minor disagreements with the
Russians but we ended up resolving them
and so let's not make a big deal there's
no reason why we can't maintain
friendship after the war when Truman
gets in there on April 12 1945 he
immediately takes a different course
Roosevelt's alliance with the wartime
alliance with the Soviets was still very
strong at that point but Truman turns to
advisors who Roosevelt never trusted in
the first place and didn't pay any heed
to people I Stettinius or Byrnes they
met the second day April 13th Forrestal
fly's burns are from South Carolina and
forestalls private plane and Tim and
Stettinius and burns give to him in the
same message the Soviets are breaking
all of their agreements they can't be
trusted
they've broken all the Yalta agreement
and and so what we're going to see is
within two weeks the US policy toward
the Soviet Union is going to change in
April of 1945 by the time there's that
big meeting on April 23rd with Molotov
in April 23rd the the United States had
changed course and so at that meeting
Truman meesa Molotov first he meets with
his advisors and they're divided Stimson
Marshall Leahy are all telling him don't
break with the Soviets that the Simpson
says very clear since was Secretary of
War and he understood he says the
Soviets have a
better understanding their own security
especially around Poland than we do just
interrupt for setting up but stepping
back from those details do you think it
was realistic for these two powerful
nations continental powers each of whom
had I think it's fair to say an empire
one informal one a little more formal
since the Soviets obviously had all
these different smaller states under
their control and and going to keep
control of the Baltic States and of
course I'm moving into Eastern Europe
with a bit armies dominion over those
areas was it realistic for these two
powers with very different ideological
basis to really get along for very long
or were they really destined to have a
cold war and and luckily never really
had a hot war except through proxies so
these details are important but who
knows of course it Roosevelt Liv what
would have happened but but arguably and
tell them as you know himself through
shock to close head of the one who has
the French Communist Party told the
American communists and 19 April 1945
get ready for the class war to continue
in effect don't don't believe that
peaceful coexistence is really going to
last ever at the same time as as
Roosevelt is dying actually but how did
you want to chime in them well you're
asking some specific ways but the French
Communist you want to deal with that
first or that I would like just to say
larger questions not as a historian but
as a young as a person who came to this
to look at World War two in a different
aspect than I ever did as a young person
when it was victory at sea is what I'm
shocked about
I would not downplay the British Empire
that's the biggest Empire of all the US
has nothing to better the British Empire
we are coming power right so is Russia
because they grow during the war Soviet
Union becomes that they aren't you don't
forget they arm themselves across the
Ural Mountains they remake themselves
it's an extraordinary story of migration
and reconstruction and dedication of the
people and the losses of the Soviets
whether it's twenty two or twenty seven
million and whether Stalin's kills it
doesn't matter the whole ideas the whole
nation plunged into this thing it was a
crucible for them the Great War
but the British had the inertial is a
fascinating overlay on all this because
he has a different emotive it seems once
the British islands are saved by the in
the Battle of Britain his goal seems to
be truly to regain the Empire he said I
did not become prime minister of this
thing to dismember the British Empire
and the whole and the whole concept of
going to North Africa sending troops up
to the southern belly of the Nazi Empire
Italy and the Balkans regaining Greece
which is a tremendous story everyone
talks about Eastern Europe there's an
outsider I'm saying well what about the
British when they went back into Greece
in 1944 and started dive-bomb in the
streets of Athens and killing the people
communists resistors who fought
valiantly against the Nazis the British
were ruthless in Athens and that's never
pointed out by the people who say oh
look at the look at what Stalin did and
in Poland or in it he broke the altar
and this is this F I don't believe that
he broke all he'll tell you more about
that but look what the British did no
never points to that and then what we
did in in Greece in nineteen in the Cold
War period the early Cold War period in
the in the Truman Doctrine 47 to 49 we
had American advisers in early Vietnam
were already over in Greece that's
jumping ahead but the British goal is
truly so as get back the Mediterranean
go on get your oil regions get Iran back
there's a conflict in Iran in 1945 and
beyond that he wants India is crucial to
Churchill that's the jewel of the Empire
we show that in the beautiful maps and
then beyond that he gets Singapore back
so he gets the Far East it is the
richest resources in the world belong to
the Bretton on us so that becomes a that
is a it's a key it's not a subplot it's
a key plot so you can't tell my
us-soviet relations without talking
about the British Empire it's a three
three parts of a cold war in the
beginning which most Americans have no
idea of and they have no idea what role
the British were playing but Roosevelt
did and Roosevelt was very very critical
of the British Empire as was his vice
president for 41 to 45 Henry Wallace the
two of them want to dismantle the
British Empire this
amantha the French Empire had the
Portuguese the Dutch they were very anti
colonial Truman as we know lets them
back in and encourage them and give them
aid and support important point yeah
Mary's out make that again because and
it gets us involved in Vietnam and it
leads to a lot of the turmoil that we
are going to later face but the other
question you were raising is a fair one
and an important one we don't know if
that and the would have been a clash
between the Americans and the Soviets we
had different interests but we had a
very good wartime alliance and at April
23rd crucial meeting Marshall and
Stimson both make the point then not
only had the so he's been good wartime
allies they had often delivered more
than they had promised and so they both
were confident that there could be
post-war friendship Eisenhower was sure
at that point that there will be
post-war friendship Eisenhower says he
didn't begin to doubt that until August
6 1945 when he got word of the atomic
bombing so I was in herre felt strongly
and and Roosevelt had felt strongly
along those lines that's why I was
focusing on those even just two weeks
how rapidly things changed in just its
first two weeks when Truman takes over
and Truman comes in and is in way over
his head which he admits to everybody it
had this recurring nightmare as vice
president that they would be knock on
his door in the middle of the night the
Secret Service would come and say the
president is dead you're president now
now was his nightmare and was a
nightmare for good reason he was not
prepared he was not chosen because he
was qualified to run when Pendergast
first chose him in 1934 to run for the
Senate Pendergast was asked by the
newspapers why did you choose Harry
Truman of all people to run for the
Senate and Pendergast says I wanted to
show the world that a well-oiled machine
could take an office boy and get him
elected to the Senate and Truman in his
first term there is considered the
senator from Pendergast he was shunned
by the other senators and even his
second term it develops more of a
national reputation but he's not expert
on any of these kinds of issues so he
gets in there and right from the
beginning every meeting he has with
people he says this is a terrible
mistake
I'm not big enough I'm not smart enough
he goes on April 13th his first day in
office
and he meets with the reporters at the
Capitol and and they that he said boys
if you pray pray for me now I don't know
if any of you ever had a load of hay
fall on you but I feel as if the moon
the stars and all the planets have
fallen on me and one of them said good
luck mr. president and Truman says I
wish you didn't have to call this a good
segue to we're back I should say were
forward in some ways to Henry Wallace
who's ah perhaps maybe two showing the
same sort of unsung hero of your book
and I know as all we're saying you know
think about working on a screenplay a
while back about about Wallace um you
know this is one of the great
counterfactuals of course of modern
American history
what if Wallace had got me nominated in
1944 and you argue in the book I know
that he came very close to it and
Senator Claude pepper from Florida was
about to nominate him and and and you
argue that the convention would have
would have gone along with that he was
much more popular certainly than the
other people there however I do want to
press you a little on that because in I
think probably the best biography of
Wallace American dreamer by Culver and
Hyde Culver former senator you know from
Iowa they they make it pretty clear at
least based on their evidence that that
FDR didn't want Wallace to run with him
that that he did say nice things to
Wallace was the office I think in the
meeting they had Jelani 1944 but then
that very evening he meets with people
who were very dead set against walls the
Machine so to speak who didn't want to
bother some people from Missouri and
others and evidently wall according to
Culver hi Wallace his name doesn't even
come up they only talk about Truman or
William O Douglas as possibilities
so if wall if it got nomination uh he
might have been running with a man a
dying man who didn't want him on the
ticket so I guess I've got a very
different reading okay having been
through every piece of that information
for a long time
I'm parties myself on their biographies
yeah no no no that's a valid percent
perspective on this what Roosevelt in
1944 was getting very ill the party
bosses knew that he was feeble that
there was almost no chance he was going
to survive another term group and they
decided that they were going to try to
get Wallace off the ticket it was run by
two people Bob Hannigan the national
chairman who ran the st. Louis machine
that got rumen reelected in 1940 and
Edie Paulie and Paulie was a California
oil millionaire who said I went into
politics when I realized it was cheaper
to elect the new Congress and to buy up
the old one
he's later going to get indicted for
good reason
and you see people whose names on the
billion yeah UCLA yes exactly exactly
yep so they decided that they're going
to try to surround Roosevelt with all
people who are hostile to Wallace to
convince him that he can't get reelected
if Wallace is on the ticket Wallace had
enemies we're not denying that I mean in
1941 when Henry Luce made his famous
speech that wrote his editorial saying
the 20th century is going to be the
American Century in the United States
going to dominate the world economically
and politically and militarily and
culturally Wallace responded to that is
vice president he made a famous speech
called the century the calm man
so the 20th century should not be the
American Century it should be the
century of the common man so what we
need is a worldwide People's Revolution
in the tradition of the French the
American the Latin American the Russian
revolutions he called for ending
colonialism ending imperialism and the
monopolies and cartels and the economic
exploitation spreading the fruits of
Science and Technology around the world
he was and he had and they had enemies
his enemies were the southern
segregationist because he was the
leading spokesperson for black civil
rights the anti-feminists because he was
a least most person for women's rights
in the party the anti-imperialists and
the Conservatives he said America's
fashion America's fascists are those
people who think wall street comes first
to the American people second so he had
enemies and those enemies wanted to get
rid of him on that ticket in 1944 the
different problem was he was enormous ly
popular on July 20th 1944 the night that
the
engine starts in Chicago Gallup released
a poll asking potential voters who they
wanted on the ticket is vice-president
65% said they wanted Wallace on the
ticket 2% said they wanted Harry Truman
so the question was how are the party
bosses going to thwart this Roosevelt
was very feeble when the party bosses
started to come to him saying they want
to get rot Wallace off the ticket what
Roosevelt says to him I support Wallace
but I can't fight this campaign myself
I'm not strong enough again I depending
on you guys to do it and and he finally
gave in and it was terrible that he did
his family was furious Eleanor Roosevelt
was furious with him every single one of
the Roosevelt kids was furious with him
they were huge Wallace supporters Walt
had the backing of Labor and blacks he
had all the black delegates at the
convention all the progressives and then
so there was a fight between the
conservatives in the party we see that
split still today in a Democratic Party
but under the southern segregationists
in there like we used to but it's still
that kind of fight and so Roosevelt
didn't have the gumption to fight at
that point in had the strength he lost
that straight but he said to Wallace it
said publicly at the convention he said
if I were a delegate I would vote for
Henry Wallace which he would have but
it's tragic as we say in the documentary
it's tragic that he didn't have the
strength to fight at that point for
Wallace I sense
I sense it in your opening question
Michael that you were pointing to the
forces of history and I see the Marxist
Leninist side of this kind of the forces
that push history Madeleine I'm in the
sense that Wallace would have been
opposed and the forces were not in his
favor and that the forces were
ultimately between God this capitalism
versus
communist ideology would clash and that
would be the end of it and that of
course was a subject of the February 46
speech Stalin made that was
misinterpreted by the West about the two
systems which actually that speech is
made a lot of by the Hawks and the
conservatives but in fact when you read
the speech and just look at the iron
curtain speech around the same time arts
yeah that my current speech is
completely hostile to the Soviet River
and that goes back to Churchill which is
a key step author in the Cold War we go
there because we go into those months by
months from July 45 right through March
46 and when Owen Churchill gives us
incredible speech but in your you know I
again I'm coming from the outside you
you studied this all your life but I'm
fascinated by the 30s and we did a
chapter on the 30s and also the
Philippine the the Woodrow Wilson period
really looked up to that and what
happens is you know it's this the
concept of communism comes and goes as
many phases in America but certainly
labor it ties to the ideas some of the
ideals of socialism and we see it in
Deb's we see it all in the union
movements of the 1870s we see it those
are even in relationship to the French
collectives you know of the 1870s 1830s
there's there's the working man's rights
the the farm movement the progressive
movement it works through American
history and Wilson kind of puts a stop
and stomp on it he comes down Debs
it goes to jail Eugene Debs goes to jail
big bill Haywood Emma Goldman all these
people disappear they they're thrown out
of the country because they resist World
War one right so these are the forces
that are moving America there's Wilson
movement towards this place we're going
to I'm curious to know what you think
those forces are where where the labor
movement is going to end up because I I
think Peter and I would that there are
moments in history pivot points where
things can truly change where there can
be a Wallace that can make that
convention moment where they can be a
candidate does this three points we
still turn in a way which could turn and
could turn again and maybe have turn in
the past
and while Assyrian came so close when I
just curious what he's thinking about
because I bet that was his first
question today I'm so see the
interviewer discussion right well you
know I think there's a big difference to
someone like Deb's and Emma Goldman and
and comm is especially Communists who
have power as talented I mean I'm a
Goldman goes to the Soviet Union well
Russia and then comes Soviet Union in in
1920-21 which is first imported in 1919
but she goes there with great hopes
thinking this is going to be the new
world and her fellow an accursed are
being rounded up and killed and and so
envy that she argues this is I think
quite rightly a tyrannical system even
if it was a system which did
industrialize the country with a
tremendous tremendous cost so I come at
it as an anti-communist leftist someone
who thinks that that Stalin was a
horrible mass murder one of the worst in
history uh and yet at the same time I
agree with both of you that the United
States is hardly blameless and did a lot
to exacerbate that robbery in the
hostility so we're gonna take a break
just in a second but but when return I'd
like to sort of move forward to the
Kennedy and talk about the credibly
dramatic turning point they didn't turn
luckily the Cuban Missile Crisis and
also talk about Vietnam advance would
you say that the American capitalists
were most were very concerned about the
labor movement both works and then
during the thirty is still always we
know we're in Michigan
well exactly that's my point the 1930s
is a key very threatening moment and
during the strikes of World War two
there were more strikes during World War
Two labor strikes and in any other time
in our history well cats yeah yeah
and it was tremendous dissatisfaction
right after the war in that 4540 secure
it goes all through film noir even you
see you know but there's dislocations in
American life and is it not convenient
for the bosses the owners the upper to
the the elites to look to deflect the
tensions that exist in the syrup in
American life by pointing to Stalin and
the Communists and saying the this is
all course this is the enemy of course
know that the the Red Scare was a scare
against the Communist Party which was
declining quickly after 1948 Progressive
Party a debacle loss for example and of
course the Cold War at the same time one
can say that American the American right
and the American corporate interests
used that fear I think to turn people
against labor against progressive forces
at the same time without denying that
waiting for the Soviets were happening
we were doing in Eastern Europe was
taking away people's independence take
away democracy killing dissidents we
write that we talk about that we're not
yeah we're not fighting your corner
these are the things where is the energy
the energy is in the United States stop
stop the strike stop labor oh yeah I
don't and this is the primary prime and
I think that the Stalin has always been
a convenient for a bogus traction
bogeyman further for the right and the
center that the Truman Heights ascended
up to today to get a wife I just wish a
communist the fact that communists were
doing what they were doing also made it
easy as a for the right to use that book
at the scare people country oh that's
what concerns made speeds when you see
all the Liberals so to speak the code or
the rules and also the Truman liberals
and the Clark Clifford's that will drift
in this direction sir and and it changes
American history termly because right
now we have no union movement I think
the concept of labor versus capital is
not even discussed in this country no
we've gone back to 19th century analysis
this is what's happened and this is far
more important frankly then pointing the
finger at
Soviet Union why not pointed it as I
said earlier at Churchill in Greece in
Athens in 1944 sources let's be let's a
little bit more we should if we can take
a break which egalitarian carrying our
critter we will we will jump forward
afterwards
sorry I just wanted toast
on the go afterwards is available via
podcast through iTunes and XML visit
book TV org and click podcasts on the
upper left side of the page select which
podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel
okay um like to jump forward to the
1960s the late great or not-so-great
1960s and talk about John F Kennedy
still perhaps the most beloved president
in American history at least the memory
of people alive now at least clearly one
of the most dramatic and scariest events
of his presidency was the Cuban Missile
Crisis in October 1962 which all of us
lived through as teenagers talk a little
bit if you would about how you think
that crisis came to be and and why it
didn't result in the nuclear holocaust
and many of us fear to would well
Khrushchev actually made a big blunder
in the Cuban Missile Crisis and that was
not just putting the missiles with the
nuclear warheads into Cuba it was not
announcing that he had done so he
undermined his own deterrence what he
was trying to deter was a US invasion of
Cuba the United States had been planning
an invasion in fact we had an event that
we had a mock invasion plan for October
of 62 called Operation or Sachs would be
second invasion after being after the
Bay of Pigs right after the failure the
Bay of Pigs and our Sakas Castro spelled
backwards the US was in heavy planning
mode for an invasion to overthrow after
the disaster of the Bay of Pigs and we'd
also been running Operation Mongoose
which was our counterinsurgency program
basically a terrorist program against
the Castro government so it was clear
that the u.s. was planning an invasion
Khrushchev thought he could kill two
birds with one stone by changing the
balance the United States was so far
ahead
and missiles and then ability to deliver
warheads that he thought if we could put
the intermediate range ballistic
missiles in Cuba then that would
somewhat offset America's big advantage
in nuclear weaponry in 1962 and it could
deter a u.s. invasion of Cuba mistake he
made was not announcing that the weapons
were there and not announcing that he
also had a hundred battlefield nuclear
weapons there we seen Isis doesn't find
out till 1992 and McNamara turned white
and almost passed that when he found out
about that so so the suspect American
Secretary of Defense's there in the 60s
and so so the Saudis put the missiles in
Cuba the United States discovers that
with our flights our surveillance
flights over there and then the tension
builds and we have a quarantine a
blockade around Cuba and one of the
things that happens during that time is
that a Soviet submarine is is found by
American by American ships and they
start to drop missile charges depth
charges on an undistorted depth charges
on this on the Soviet submarine they
knocked out the electrical system the
carbon dioxide was rising people were
passing out inside the submarine they
have no communications with the Kremlin
the commander of the submarine
savitsky says load the torpedoes let's
attack the world war probably started
already
up above we're not going to talk doing
summersaults down here when the war is
starting we're not going to squeeze our
country it's home to launch the nuclear
torpedo
they said it ready to launch fortunately
one of the other commanders on the ship
who had a lower rank talked him out of
it was the name was arkhipov arkhipov
might have saved the world this is this
unknown Soviet sub commander he talked
savitsky out of launching the nuclear
torpedo had he launched a nuclear
torpedo world war 3 would have started
right there hello and we certainly but
then even after that we came very close
we were planning the invasion it's
amazing how little we knew about what
we're going to find we had we had seen
where 33 of the 42 irbm s were located
we didn't see the other ones we had no
idea what the nuclear warheads were we
had never discovered them
our plan was to invade and also to bomb
destroy the Soviet facilities there we
later found that we assumed that the
Soviets had 10,000 troops there and that
there were a hundred thousand armed
Cubans we later find out that the
Soviets had forty three thousand troops
there and there were two hundred seventy
thousand armed Cubans so our initial
plan was if we invaded we would take 18
thousand casualties 4,500 dead when
McNamara found out how many troops there
actually were there he said that would
have been 25,000 dead and then he found
out that they also had a hundred
battlefield nuclear weapons that would
likely have been using American forces
he said a hundred thousand Americans
would have been killed we would have
absolutely destroyed Cuba and very
likely thinking out the Soviet Union
also so we came that close to him
fortunately Kennedy and Khrushchev were
both doing everything they could to try
to prevent the nuclear war and they
finally succeeded but he came very close
to them not succeeding Kennedy said the
chances were one out of two that we
would have had nuclear war Khrushchev
thought they were even closer than that
he thought that this American invasion
had begun
it sounds like Kubrick's great film dr.
Strangelove was was in many ways a
enactment although they hadn't gotten
together and Christian and Cooper had no
way to know how close he was the actual
truth of always happening that you'd
agree with with most stories that this
was a key turning point in the Cold War
yeah yeah that Kennedy yet was was much
more friendly towards the brink and not
yeah when Peter doesn't mention that all
the 1950's prelude to this period is
brinksmanship on the part of Dulles and
Eisenhower using the nuclear threat to
blackmail so there's a there's a
background here but this is so close to
the edge and it really was one of the
scariest moments of mankind just as we
as teenagers a moment in human history
suss injure said oh yeah we didn't know
this we were teenagers but my god I just
some grateful we don't I mean that's why
all this criticism of Canada
all this after quarterbacking but my god
we wouldn't even be here to talk because
LeMay wanted to invade and afterwards
LeMay said we were defeated general
Curtis LeMay and have a joint Jesus
death or Air Force secretary the Air
Force Air Pacific was a mistake Ella may
have been the one who ran the bombing
against the Japanese in World War two
the fire bombing you know her end the
story about the bombing of the Japanese
in World War two before the atomic bomb
you know so Kennedy slows in the next
few months Khrushchev especially as
pootie's pushing him let's solve this
let's not have things get out of control
I guess of writes a great letter after
they says maybe good can come from this
evil and Khrushchev says let's let's
eliminate every crisis point that can
lead to another conflict between us and
Kennedy is initially very slow to
respond is that one reason why quick
trip gets overthrown though because he's
seen is too because he backed down you
he backed down in the Cuban Missile
Crisis and and then they never became
for that just like people never forgave
Kennedy for backing down in the Cuban
Missile Crisis the Joint Chiefs led by
the may were furious is that we lost
let's go and invade now and it was over
and this is one of it but Khrushchev
reaches out and Kennedy responds slowly
but first we realized that Norman
Cousins goes over there meets with
Khrushchev a crew say was very
frustrated and cousin says wow he's
really serious because the editor of
review at which used to be an important
magazine and and to exist an Averell
Harriman as says the same thing free
Chef sincere he wants peace and Kennedy
responds and Kenny responds in a number
of places he had already neutralized the
accepted a neutral dissolution allows
which made people very angry in the
Joint Chiefs but now he says let's end
the space race that was his signature
initiative and he says why should we
compete going to the moon let's do it
together let's collaborate and he and he
and we believe he gives strong
indications that he wants to pull out of
Vietnam and and his American University
speech which I think is the most
visionary speech by an American
president in twentieth century basically
calls for freedom speech is pretty
visual it's got a few and FDR has a
couple others that are wonderful but
this is a great great speech
if commencement arrests in June of 63
basically says let's end the Cold War
and and he's reaching out so he's
responding both both of them are
reaching out toward each other they sign
the the test ban treaty the limited test
ban treaty which is a major milestone
major victory
there's a series of things that are
taking place during this time Kennedy
also learned some other lessons as was
we talked about and one of them after
the Bay of Pigs was don't trust the CIA
and don't trust the Joint Chiefs he
refers to those Joint Chiefs sons of
[ __ ] and of CIA bastards and said I'm
going to destroy the CI said I'm going
to tear it into a thousand pieces and
scatter them in the wind and so he's had
a lot of enemies because desire knows he
fires and follows the three big people
isn't the CIA
and he puts the CIA operatives under the
ambassadors in the various countries and
they were furious about that also so we
see Kennedy is a lot of these and other
things a real change of mind after the
Cuban Missile Crisis we see a new
Kennedy Neff the Cuban Missile Crisis a
visionary Kennedy Kennedy wanted and the
war is now here's live but that's the
tragedy yeah that's the tragedy yes why
do you call your Airport Dulles Airport
I find that to be insulting its Reagan
muster but and Reagan Airport I'm sorry
at least we got Thurgood Marshall in
Baltimore I wasn't involved in that
decision now obviously one of the last
things that happens well Kimmy's alive
that has a very important impact on
foreign policy is is the assassination
of the M the the president of South
Vietnam our our client our ally over
there and then three weeks later I think
the three weeks later Kennedy is himself
is assassinated and as you were saying
before this raised the question that
that historians have been arguing about
probably since Kennedy's death and will
probably keep arguing about of in next
50 years would Kennedy have wanted to
would he have pulled out American troops
out of Vietnam
what do you pull out the advisors out of
Vietnam we didn't have yet have as you
know troops any great numbers there are
combat troops there and you argue I
think that that
indications are that he would have and
you and you cite various sources about
that just curious just to challenge that
a little bit there's a wonderful book by
very good diplomatic historian Frederick
log of all called choosing war which you
probably know in which he says that
Vietcong attacks were doubling in
November from the month before in South
Vietnam and that there were meetings of
Kennedy's top advisors in Honolulu which
I think finished up just a day before
Kennedy was assassinated this would be a
great film and and they warned evidently
that the Vietcong were going to win if
if the u.s. didn't do something very
quickly so not to challenge the memories
of people who were involved in this of
course and say Kennedy would have pulled
out but wouldn't it have presented
Kennedy if he had lived with with a very
difficult choice that is losing to a
peasant a peasant army in effect a
guerrilla force which was obviously
being backed by the Soviet yeah but
Kennedy had I think we make the argument
that Kennedy had been under pressure
from the Joint Chiefs in an enormous way
at the Cuban Missile Crisis and also at
the Bay of Pigs and he had said no so he
was the one who could stand up to him
that hold that meeting in halle-loo by
the way was mentioned to me years ago by
Fletcher Prouty it was the mr. X and
Jeff cases it was his very strange
saying that these guys were all meeting
in Honolulu that's most of the cabinet
was were out of the country when they
when the president was killed in Dallas
it seems to have been a one could argue
that Johnson very quickly met on that
Monday whether were the day that before
Kennedy was buried was a Sunday I think
Johnson met very quickly with the Joint
Chiefs and clearly indicated that he was
going to reverse the candidate policy
and in January a few months two months
later he initiated the new NSM NSA M 273
which essentially allowed for enormous
jump acceleration in covert warfare
against
north and that plan had a lot to do with
the gulf of tonkin
hello Kennedy if the Johnson approach to
war it's an interesting statement I came
I never heard it before when Johnson
told Doris Goodwin later in his life
that after he'd been the presidency he
said you know I gave up the Great
Society because I did not want to lose
in Vietnam
such was his it's a crazy choice you
know that no he just the concept of
being seen as weak haunted Johnson
whereas I we argue that it did not haunt
Kennedy he'd been in war he'd seen the
suffering he'd been actually been a
combat in a way that he saw you know he
saw two feet and he knew defeat much of
his life his older brother was killed in
a war and he he'd been to Vietnam and he
has brought his brother Robert later was
very eloquent when he said Daniel
Ellsberg well I have what is the senator
yes yes that was a really important
point because when Dan Ellsberg
interviewed Robert Kennedy in 67 this
was before a lot of people change their
views after the the Tet Offensive in 68
in a 67 before that when most people
were still supporting the war the NL's
burg interviewed Ken Robert Kennedy and
Robert Kennedy says we would never have
sent combat troops in there this is as
we would have gotten out and Kennedy's
and rut Dan says to him how come you
were so smart how come you were so
prescient and then Dan says he almost
jumped out of his seat when Robert
answered because Robert says because we
were there we were there in 51 we saw
what was happening we saw with the
French we knew that they couldn't win
this kind of thing and he says that we
would have just fudged it up we would
have said we were asked to leave we were
invited to leave or we had won or was
neutral but mathematically close that's
what he said quote and MacArthur is
quote - Kennedy - I mean Kennedy kept on
whenever they people pushed Kennedy
Kennedy met with MacArthur MacArthur
said you'd have to have your head
examined if you got the u.s. involved in
a ground war in Asia and people and
Kenny would always probably it's
repeated like 40 years three years
remember Robert Gates about Afghanistan
and he's right they were both right and
Kennedy took that lesson but also
McNamara had drawn a
the plan for NSA M 263 was called for
taking a thousand troops out before the
end of 1963 and all US troops out by
1965 and McNamara was asked but what if
the United States was losing and
McNamara says we would have taken them
out anyway that was our plan that was
our policy we have a lot of other people
Kennedy mentioned to a lot of people is
63 that this was his plan he says I
can't do it now or else we'll be a
right-wing rebellion and we'll lose the
64 election said but after I'm reluctant
I'm going to do it and he says this to
Tip O'Neill and Roger Hillsman is that
true I mean having with the Pentagon
Papers in a while you I'm sure you much
more up on them the Pentagon Papers a
secret history of the war that was
written Dan Ellsberg was you know okay
mr. man became famous by releasing them
to the public to the press of course to
the public but isn't it true the
Pentagon Papers talk about ninety 64 in
Vietnam as this time when the Vietcong
is gaining territory a lot of territory
so so perhaps by the 64 election this
would have been a major issue for
Kennedy and he would have to come on
more hawkish again he's a counterfactual
but but we think that Kennedy had a
certain kind of self-confidence and he
Kennedy said at one point that if
somebody comes into and argues with me
about unemployment because I can refute
him I have no problem so but if
something from something from the
intelligence community or the military
comes in I always assume used to assume
that they had a special knowledge that I
didn't have since I've learned different
that they really don't and he said to a
later point he said I'm going to tell my
my successor that the most important
thing he has to learn is not to trust
the military not to trust the Joint
Chiefs Kennedy stood up to those people
in the audience and nine Obama had the
contrary result with the generals
pressing him on Afghanistan the surge
there do you think I think I know which
will answer this but I want to hear you
talk about it as American as American
foreign policy in the grand sense
changed at all since the Cold War ended
it's been over for you know more than 20
years now and as US still seeing the
world
as it's our to be to be cracked open so
to speak I can answer your own question
yes yes you know I want to hear you talk
about it because because most people
would assume well yes
at least until 9/11 the u.s. aware being
personally I mean again I'm not a
historian I came from this from the
outside but it's just a heartbreaker
it's there was a season of peace in the
late 80s with Reagan and Gorbachev
reaching some agreements on it on
nuclear arms and then when Bush comes
into office in January 18 on of course
Dukakis was my choice but he and he was
leading but in the race but he doesn't
May Bushman comes in he has a golden
opportunity this is a Truman Stalin
moment mm-hmm this is Gorbachev is
offering him as you said an oyster it's
going to take all the Soviet troops out
of Eastern Europe he's going to let NATO
take over Germany they gonna they're
gonna unite Germany and NATO can have
their Germany but as long as NATO
doesn't go further east these kinds of
things are in the air what does Bush do
gentlemen square happens he suspends
relations but behind the scenes he does
business as usual in China he goes into
Panama in December 89 I'll never forget
that because I had born in the 4th of
July was opening that same day killed
our business that we get the American
people loved it then they back the
invasion it was over back you it was our
backyard it was a war on drugs and that
was a new issue now communism had been
forgotten there was a war on drugs and
Noriega was looked like the the bad guy
of the month he was a new Stalin at that
point so we recoveries north that we
couldn't depend upon then it within a
year later we had this Iraq one and
that's another untold story because the
Iraq one war is really depressing when
you go into the all the false
intelligence and the doctrine of the
photos Peter you want to talk a bit
about it because it really breaks my
heart
personally and then of course is a
veteran from the other you know more I
see the next 10 years we draft we don't
take advantage of the possibilities with
the Soviet Union
to keep it stable we probably privatized
any privatizing with Russia and then by
the time Bush 43 comes in it's not only
squandered but it's the nightmare really
began so for me it's it's really
heartbreaking that period mmm did you
want to come
well I of course agree with everything
Oliver saying there and me as we see it
as a lost opportunity we have a lot of
lost opportunities in the 20th century
in March 5th 1953 when Stalin dies the
Soviet leaders reach out to the United
States they're talking about ending the
Cold War at that point and we end Isen
Howard gives into Dulles Eisenhower
makes a great speech immediately and
then Dulles refutes it basically two
days later and the United States takes a
hard line Cold War policy when it was a
chance then we've had a lot of chances
to reverse things and 1989 was another
one about the would the winds of peace
blowing across the world in 1989
Gorbachev is reaching out and Bush
doesn't reach back doesn't reciprocate
doesn't meet him half white and in the
situation in the kind of a stalemate in
the 1990s and then at the end of the
decade but even at there in that time
the assumptions is still there the
Wilson idea Woodrow Wilson says after
Versailles now the world will realize
that the United States is a savior of
the world but Madeline Albright
as Secretary of State says that the that
if we use force is because we're the
United States of America we're the
indispensable nation we stand taller and
see farther than other countries that's
the way it looks from the United States
standpoint Samuel Huntington who I don't
usually agree with said something that I
find very very profound
he said the West won the world not by
the superiority of its ideas or values
of religion but by the superiority of
the application of organized violence
it's as Westerners often forget that
fact non-westerners never do and so
Albright does as well as justifiable
that we can have this policy toward Iraq
even though a half million children have
died and Clinton passes the law that
basically gives the
eat the opportunity for Bush to go
further with it when Bush after 9/11
with the invasion of Iraq so that we see
a continuum that's part of the point
we're making it's not Democrats versus
Republicans foreign policy is largely
bipartisan in the 20th century and and
we see this trend running these lines
running from 1898 really you can say
1846 with Mexico we're tracing it from
1898 and 1899 up through Iraq and
Afghanistan and Yemen and to the current
administration's a lot like great
historian no longer with us William atma
Williams who argued took my empires as a
way of life so you tell you book untold
history of the United States but in some
ways Wayne Matten Williams was telling
this we're [ __ ] we're following in
her footsteps it on and I'm standing on
the shoulders of a lot of great
historians
I mean what we're saying is not really
untold to the university audiences or
university historians its untold in the
public schools its untold to a popular
audience until people get their history
from television of course and movies
other than Oliver's and and so that's
what we're trying to challenge but
Americans don't know much history the
national report card issued last year
said that the Americans were actually
worse u.s. high school seniors are worse
and understand the u.s. history than
they are and understanding math and
science and we always be moan the fact
that they're so weak in math and science
but only 12% of high school seniors
showed proficiency in US history 12% but
it was amazing thing was that the the
report also said that only 2% actually
could explain what Brown versus Board of
Education was about even though the
answer was implicit in the way the
question was asked so our kids don't
know much history and a lot of what they
know is wrong and certainly greater
stories we may this book is based upon
the work of great historians you're
mentioned in there may there's a lot of
good historians who are doing similar
kind of work but we're doing is we've
got a big sweep and because we're able
to couple this with the Showtime
documentary able to make it more
dramatic and while I'm telling we
probably do make it
primer you know like an honest - basic
text like a history 101 why can it not
be I mean I have to say when you read
these history books it's it's not it's
not coherent there's no pattern so we
don't see what we're just talking about
this Empire you don't understand how
that works and the kids they get the
dates they get the pictures but they
don't really are they're not interested
because to some degree the United States
always comes out ahead always comes out
okay we can trash Iraq twice so we
through the history of most countries if
you if you take Chinese history and
China there's a mix but though concept
is to go for a global history or to see
it through Russian eyes Chinese eyes
franchise that's what was written well
what's made Henry Wallace unique is that
he saw the world not just for us eyes he
kept on saying to Truman well look at
what how what we're doing looks to the
Russians look at the Soviets and we
don't have that ability
Obama has some of that ability and
certainly we were very hopeful in the
beginning
let's let this talk about a little bit
because your chapter on Obama is
entitled provocatively um well you don't
forget the title you say he took a bad
situation in certain ways made it worse
yes people energy in a wounded Empire
yeah it's the longest chapter in the
book yes you go hiking longer in the
revised edition while he's still in
Paris I will be four four you're going
to see the cuts we have to make on the
air in the film though we deal with a
bigger concept I think the he has to
deal with the contemporary there's a lot
of interest in Obama but you know
sometimes you know closer you get I mean
the idea of this other documentary is we
have to pull back and see the forest
sure but obviously there are people both
on the right and people support Obama
and people who don't like Obama who
would disagree yes who would say who
would say he's you know apologizing for
America he's pulling out before our
allies can stand on their own and of
course yes the people who say that he
shouldn't have
like you say she really should have sent
troops in to Afghanistan in the first
place more troops more troops yes he was
boxed in mm-hmm by in Petraeus and
McChrystal and gates and Clinton he had
a tough group around him it was partly
his own doing though one of the things
we criticized him for that the advisors
he brought in the New York Times called
his economic advisors a constellation of
rubra Knights and they were they were
Timothy Geithner and Larry Summers and
Orszag means or will Wall Street people
he brought in so some of those policies
were not surprising and his foreign
policy team Robert Gates has been up to
his eyeballs and most of the bad things
that this country is done for decades
didn't he promised in his campaign 2008
that he would pull troops out of Iraq
and did more emphasis on Afghanistan yes
so in some ways he was just following
through on his promise no yes yes most
of us who supported him strongly and
still do were didn't take him seriously
enough when he said that and and then
and we think it's been a big mistake
that that he's done that but we're
disappointed on a number of fronts one
thing he said he's going to be the
transparency president that he was going
to cut back on all of Bush's secrecy and
in most ways he hasn't followed through
between 1917 when the Espionage Act was
passed in 2008 three people were
indicted under the Espionage Act Bob
himself has indicted six we were very
critical a lot of things but one is the
treatment for example of Bradley Manning
and his campaign against Assange
losing their that the way Isonzo
released the first set of documents was
very problematic but this is not the our
enemy in some ways what we're saying is
that you've got a Obama refused to go
after Bush and Cheney
for war crimes they committed Manning is
being incarcerated for exposing the war
crimes so it so if you commit war crimes
you walk free if you expose war crimes
you get sent to jail in this
administration his drug policy is very
problematic
his hands on approach to targeting
people for assassination is very
problematic the case like Yemen al-qaeda
had 300 supporters in Yemen before we
started our drone campaign last year
they had 700 they've got more than that
now we think it backfires
for example the Times Square bomber you
know we have one minute left I think so
I just want to interrupt but if you know
- like your since you've been working on
this this incredible series and this
very you know impressive book behind
this is not exactly kind of factual but
a counter vision if you will he just
talked I mean what kind of foreign
policy do you think US should have if
you were if you were Secretary of State
and President and Secretary of Defense
what would you do I would take the enemy
wallis approach compassion and the love
of mankind and a global purpose what he
called what was the speech that the
century of the common man this is it
seems to be imperative now because we
have more knowledge and the world's can
cooperate and has on many fronts
medically certainly and economically I
think that the globalization is not
about us feeding as a bigger shark but
it's about us cooperating that's the
century I would like to live in yeah so
we've got a world in which the richest
300 people or so have more wealth than
the poorest 3 billion where there's six
wal-mart heirs have more wealth than the
bottom 30% of the United States where
the richest 1% the United States have
more wealth in the bottom 90%
but we need to redistribute resources
and I deal further and they'll say the
bad guys they always say the same thing
they say well you can't live like that
that's idealistic because there's always
a bad guy out there what will the
Russians do what will the Chinese do now
it's the Chinese this is an old argument
and it goes all the way back we've we
end up being the worst guy we become the
bad guy because no one else acts worse
than we do because we don't trust
anybody I think we've got the power for
sin and and ironically we do because it
was our space weaponry at this point and
which is now becoming devolving into a
space electronic shield right you'd say
a space shield triple-canopy according
to zambia by 2020 2025
we could we could become this fascist
force in the universe we are this
fascist force in the universe for
control now this is a key moment it's
like the Star Wars moment in George
Lucas you know are you going to follow
our conscience or our good sense our
heart or were you going to follow our
baser instincts that's probably good way
to end thank you all the snow on it
because thank you Michael